hi there welcome to this new video
lesson where we going to learn about
clot formation I'm Samuel and AW
solution architect cloud evangelist and
trainer working for central ax in this
section we're going to learn about why
we need a solution called cloud
formation or why we need a product
called cloud formation and we're going
to talk in detail about what is cloud
formation and then how cloud formation
works and the concepts involved in cloud
formation like I know templates and
stacks there's some concepts involved in
cloud formation we're going to talk
about that and how do we maintain access
control over a cloud formation we're
going to talk about that as well in this
video and then we're going to go through
a demo or a lab where we create an lamp
stack environment from a template
through cloud formation and then we're
going to talk about some use cases one
of which include being able to create
and redeploy able template using cloud
formation that's a very good use case
we're going to talk about that in this
video so let's talk about why cloud
formation so when the number of products
and services grow more and managing them
and maintaining them becomes an tedious
work and cloud formation it sort of
eases that environment
now cloud formation is really an
infrastructure as the code and it sort
of solves all the problem that we
discussed sometime back and with cloud
formation we can actually create a
perfect clone of the server
configuration at any point in time and
we can also manage the configuration
changes and configuration changes with
cloud formation we can manage the
configuration changes across the
environment and not only that we can
easily Ember in the error hoc changes to
our existing environment so one might
ask why use cloud formation let's look
at the current problem that we have
creating and managing multiple AWS
resource in the portal is a big task
especially when you need to replace some
services it becomes an bigger task now
cloud formation eases that work let me
explain it in detail now at the moment
without the cloud formation or
environments that don't use cloud
formation have this problem that is
lot of time is being spent on building
the infrastructure and less focus and
less time at the moment is being given
on developing that application that runs
on that environment
that's because majority of the time is
consumed by building the environment and
if we need to redeploy the same
environment again and again the same
happens in a cycle again in a new
environment do we start from the scratch
build environment and then put
application on top of it
now that can be avoided using cloud
formation now without cloud formation
still is a problem because the resource
or the bandwidth that is needed for the
application development is not provided
because that's taken by developing the
infrastructure and to solve that problem
we can use cloud formation now that
leads to a discussion about what is
cloud formation so let's talk about or
let's try understanding what cloud
formation is cloud formation is a
service that provides users a simple way
to create and manage collection of AWS
resources by provisioning and updating
them in an very orderly and in a
predictable way if I need to expand
explanation of cloud formation cloud
formation is an service that really
helps us to model and set up our Amazon
Web Services our resources so we can
spend less time on managing the
resources and show more focus on the
application that runs on top of it we
can simply create a template for an ec2
instance or for an RDS instance and
upload it in the cloud formation portal
and cloud formation will provision and
configure those resources based on the
template that we define we really don't
have to sort out the complexities in
dependency between those applications
once the template is vetted and
validated cloud formation takes the
responsibility of handling the
dependencies between the application in
an orderly and a predictable way it
creates those services and makes it
available for us once the template is
fully run so in short the cloud
formation it allows us to create and
model our infrastructure and
applications without we having to
perform the manual action for example
the well-known company called Expedia is
able to easily manage and run its entire
front and back-end
resources they run on Arab leaders in
CloudFront what does that mean they are
spending less time on managing the
infrastructure and more time on the core
business and application that runs on
top of it and we're still talking about
what cloud formation is with cloud
formation it enables us to manage our
complete infrastructure or AWS resource
in a text file now we're going to see
that in a moment you know it's either a
JSON or an YAML file and that file is
called as the template to begin with the
resources the template provision is
called this stack all right so the
abstract from the code is called the
template and the resource that it
provisions is called the stack and this
stack can be I mean it's going to run
resources obviously and those resources
can be updated as well it's not like
once you create a stack it's done if you
need a change you need to go create
another resource that's not needed this
stack is an updatable stack let's say if
I'm including two more servers if I'm
sort of extending my environment it's
branching out to another application now
I'm including another functionality in
my environment all those can be embedded
in the update and can be updated so like
I said the stack is an updatable one now
let's talk about what the template can
do or some features and functionality of
the template now using a template we can
almost include all the application and
resources that a user might require
let's say you know after the ec2
instance is provision running an
application on top of it and you want to
template ice that and include that in
the template that's possible as well and
these templates are portable ones
meaning I can use the template in one
region and I can use the same template
in another region and that's going to
build a very similar environment in
another region I can also share that
with the customer and when they run it
it's going to run an environment from
the portable template in their account
in their environment of course all the
security is taken care I'm just saying
that if we need to build a resource if
you need to build an architecture if you
need to build an environment which looks
very similar to the other envelope man
that is possible and and these templates
are usable by the user of some sections
in the template
like the parameter section the mapping
section the condition section within the
template is what makes the templates
reusable and we will talk about
parameters mapping and conditions down
the line we're still talking about AWS
how AWS CloudFormation works and we're
gonna talk about how a template becomes
an infrastructure where it's just begin
with one request template and the
template would be in JSON or YAML format
so one would develop a template based on
the requirement based on number of ec2
instances based on whether one a load
balancer based on what they want and a
Windows server based on whether they
want and database server in that
environment and then based on the
applications that we'll be running on
top of it that can be templatized in the
code itself
so one creates a code and then the code
is saved locally or they can be put in
an s3 bucket from which the cloud
formation will call the template and
provision the resource right so we use
cloud formation to create a stack or
create the resource defined in the
template and cloud formation analyzes
the template first validates template
and then it identifies the dependencies
between them and then it starts
provisioning the resource one after the
other for example if you need five
servers in a new VPC obviously it's
going to create the vbc first and
servers second and stack let's
understand the two major components in
cloud formation by now you might have
guessed it the two major components are
the template and the stack together the
aid or they complement cloud formation
and that's out the resource or provision
that's others those are managed and that
eases the job of the administrator who
is managing the environment so let's
talk about template first a templated
cloud formation is an text file or a
formatted text file in JSON or YAML
language and that the code or the
template or the text file there actually
describes how your infrastructure looks
like or will look like once provision
and for us to create the template or for
us to you know modify an existing
template we can use a tool available
called
cloud formation designer from the
console or any text editing tool that's
available but I would recommend the
cloud formation designer though that has
rich graphics in it and these templates
are build off or they consist of nine
main objects the first of which is the
format version and this really
identifies the capabilities of the
template based on the version number and
then the second object in a template
would be description and this helps us
to include any arbitrary comments about
the template for what reason are we
building this template what's the
purpose of it stuff like that and then
we have the object called metadata in a
template and that includes a details
about the template details of the
resources in the template and then we
have the optional parameter section this
really helps us to customize our
template now parameters enable us to
input custom values to our template each
time we create or update and stack and
the mapping object it helps us to match
a key to a corresponding set of name
values for example if you want to set a
value based on region then we get to
create a mapping that uses region name
as the key and then the value that we
want to specify for each specific
regions and then we have conditions
object this is again an optional object
with this we can include statements that
define when a resource is created or
when a property is defined for example
we can compare whether a value is equal
to another value and based on the result
of that condition we can conditionally
create additional resources and then the
object called transform it's it's an
optional object as well and this
transform section specifies one or more
transforms that we can use in our cloud
formation template for example AWS
CloudFormation transforms helps simplify
template authoring by condensing the
expression arte Robles infrastructure as
a code or the cloud formation template
and it enables reuse of template
components for example we can
multiple line resources declaring it
into a single line in our template now
we will talk about all these examples in
the upcoming slides and then we have the
required section called resource that
declares the AWS resource that you want
to include in the stack for example if
you want to include an ec2 instance if
you want to include an s3 bucket we
would be using the resource object in
our stack and then we have object called
output this output object it's an
optional object in the template and it
helps us to sort of declare the outputs
that we can import into other stacks or
we can actually show it on the cloud
formation console for example if you
want the output of the or the name of
the s3 bucket that got created in
response to a cloud formation template
now we can have that output into an
output section in the cloud formation
console itself so it's sort of easy for
us to identify the resources that the
template provisioned so with all of
those objects put together this is how a
full-blown CloudFormation template with
all the objects included is going to
look like now this includes optional and
mandatory object let's talk about those
objects in detail in the upcoming
section alright let's now discuss each
and every object of this template
structure and let's begin our discussion
with the format version the format
version it really defines the
capabilities of the template the latest
version format version as of now is the
one that was updated on 2010 now the
value of the template format version it
has to be an string and if we really
don't specify the format version
CloudFormation automatically assumes the
latest version talking about description
descriptions are really any comments
that help ourselves that we want amburn
in the template itself that can be a
description and this description in a
template it has to be an string the
length of the string can be between 0 to
124 bytes in length the metadata's are
really used in the template to provide
any additional information using the
JSON and llamó objects
and metadata holds some implementation
details of a specific resource and
parameters are really a way to customize
the template each time we create or
update or stack these parameters are the
ones that helps us to give some custom
value to the template during runtime in
the example shown below and the
parameter named the instance type
parameter
it lets us to specify the ec2 instance
type for the stacks to use when creating
or updating the stack but default as we
see it's picking T to micro and this is
the value that will get picked
if we don't provision another value to
it and mapping mapping really enables us
to map a key to a corresponding named
value that we specify in a conditional
parameter and also we can deter I've the
map or a try the values in the map using
the function find in map in strict
function let's take this example let's
say based on a region if we want to set
values in a template we can create a
mapping that uses a key and holds the
value that you want to specify for each
region and the object conditions can be
used when we want to reuse the templates
by creating resources in a totally
different context for example in a
template
during stack creation all the conditions
that we mentioned in the template are
evaluated and any resources that are
associated and that come up to be true
are created and any condition that fails
or invalid are kind of ignored
automatically and the check moves
forward to the next condition and
conditional is an optional object and it
includes statement that define when a
resource is created or when a property
is actually defined for example you can
create whether for example you can
compare whether a value is equal to
another value and based on the result of
that condition we can conditionally
create resources if you have multiple
conditions then they are generally
separated with commas sometimes
conditions are very helpful when we want
to create templates and we want to reuse
those templates which was created for
one environment to another environs
example if you want to use a template
that was created in a test environment
in a development conditions would be
helpful for example in a production
environment we might want to include
instances with certain capabilities and
in a test environment we might want to
include instances with some reduced
capability in them for saving money and
condition helps us to sort of create
resources based on the environment it
will be used in we can also use
intrinsic functions to define conditions
like equals we can also use our
conditions we can use not functions
intrinsic functions in a condition and
when put together the syntax is going to
look like the one that you see on the
screen now the optional object called
transform it specifies one or more
transforms that the cloud formation uses
to process our template now these
transform sections are built on a simple
declarative language of AWS
CloudFormation with a powerful macro
system that helps us to reuse the
templates or the template competence and
they really help us to condense or
simplify our codes by enabling reuse of
the template components for example
condense a multiple line resource
declaration into a single line in our
template the resource section it really
declares the AWS resource that you want
to include in their stack such as ec2
instance such as s3 bucket and some of
the resource fields are the logical ID
the resource type and the properties
let's talk about them in briefs the
logical ID is unique within the template
and the logical ID name it actually
reference the resource in other parts of
the template in this case it's my bucket
for example and if we want to map an
elastic block store volume or if you
want to map and name of the bucket in
another place in the template then we
would use the logical ID and again in
this case it is my bucket a logical name
has the physical ID with which we
actually assign the resource for example
in this case my s3 bucket was named as
my bucket to be
and the resource type in the template it
identifies that the type of the resource
is an s3 bucket and the properties are
the additional optional information that
we can specify to our resource for
example if it is an ec2 instance let's
say we would like to know which AMI it
used then property section really
defines the ami that was used or ami as
the property of the instance so this
section describes the output value that
needs to be imported to other stacks or
the output value and that needs to be
shown in the console for the user to
easily navigate to the resource that are
being created for example for a steel
bucket name we can declare an output and
once the bucket is created we can
actually declare the output and sort of
import the name of the bucket in a
different place in the console so it's
it's easy to view instead of you know
the user getting confused and going to
s3 and searching for the bucket maybe
this can be made available in the cloud
formation console itself and the output
feels it can include some of these
followings like the logical ID it's
actually the identifier of the current
output and it's very unique within the
template and it can also include a
description description is really a
string type that describes the output
value and it can also include value and
value is the property that was returned
by the AWS CloudFormation describe Stax
command let's talk about the template
the soles attribute in this section
we're going to talk about attributes
that you can add to a resource to
control additional behavior and
relationships so let's talk there are
many these hoes at R abused a lot of
which we have if you need to name them
we have a creation policy and then we
have deletion policy it depends on
metadata attribute update policy
attribute let's talk about each of them
separately
when we associate the create policy
attribute with the resource it actually
delays the resource configuration
actions before proceeding with the stack
creation I mean the attribute stack
creation is delayed till the time the
cloud
formation receives some number of
success signals back I mean this is a
very good use case when we do auto
scaling and this creation policy can be
used only with limited number of
services like auto scaling and ec2
instances some of the use cases would be
if you want to install and software
application on ec2 instance you might
want the applications to be running
before it proceeds further so in this
case we would use the creation policy
attribute to the instance and then send
the success signal after the
applications are installed and
configured then cloud formation goes to
the next step here in the syntax that
we're looking at the auto scaling
creation policy and the minimum
successful instance percentage it's
actually a number of signals that it
will have to reply back before it can
move forward using deletion policy it
preserves backing up of the sources when
the stack is getting deleted and by
default if you don't have a deluge
policy the data gets deleted just like
that but if you use an deletion policy
we would be able to preserve the data by
taking a snapshot of it or just letting
the resource and moving on with deleting
the other resources in the stack and we
specify the delete policy attribute for
each resource specifically that we want
to control and if there are no deletion
policy mentioned for a particular
resource the cloud formation simply
deletes their resources as that's its
default behavior and if you want to keep
the resource when the stack is deleted
we use we mention a retain in the Delic
policy and that simply retains the
resource from getting deleted so in this
example we're actually retaining and
dynamodb table rest of the resources in
the stack will get deleted and using
that depends on attribute we actually
create an order in which the resource
gets deleted for example if I map one
resource to another resource and say
that this resource depends on the other
resource the other resource gets created
first then followed by this instance or
this resource so with the depends on
attribute we can specify that the
creation of specific resource is
actually followed by an another
when we add the depends on attributes to
a resource the resource is created only
after the creation of the resource
specified by the depends on attribute
let's take this example in this example
we're saying that the resource X depends
on Y will say that X depends on Y so in
this case when cloud formation is
executing it's going to deploy Y first
because it has some resources that
depends on it it's going to create Y
first and then it's going to create the
resource call X on the same context
let's say in the template we say that an
ec2 is going to depend on s3 and when
the color formation is executing it's
going to create an s3 bucket first and
then the ec2 instance that's probably
because the codes needed for the ec2
instance are stored in the s3 bucket and
and what we're looking at is the syntax
of how the depends on template resource
attribute will look like this is how it
actually will look like when we put it
in the cloud formation the instance
depends on the buckets the other
template resource attribute is metadata
metadata ours are the one that really
helps us to associate our resources with
the structured data and by including
this attribute in our template or by
including this attribute to a resource
we can specify the data in JSON or an ml
language for example in this section of
the template we're creating a V PC and
the metadata explains our metadata
defines that the V PC is part of the
region us East one and the update policy
template or source attribute in cloud
formation we can manage and replace the
updates of the instance in an auto
scaling group for example you looking at
this sample where it says that the
update policy will it replace the
instance in an auto scaling group or not
so depending on what the value is for
the will replace section whether it's
true or false depending on that the
update policy will replace the instance
or will replace the auto scaling group
itself when it's doing and rolling
deployment
that we've discussed about templates
let's talk about aw stacks as well now
we know that
aw stacks are the actual resources that
yes generated that gets created because
we ran a template it's a stack as a
collection of AWS resource that you know
we can manage in a single unit in other
words you know we can create a stack of
data stack or delete a stack and that
will actually create update delete the
collection of resources within the stack
and all the resources in the stack are
really defined by the cloud formation
template and a stack or instance can
include all the resources required to
run a web application such as a web
server a database server and some
networking rules that come along with it
all that gets embora in a stack and
let's say if we want to delete all the
resources that were created by template
that is in a separate stack we can
simply delete the stack and that would
sort of delete all the resources that is
in the stack so it sort of helps us to
manage all the resources in a single
unit or as a single unit so to summarize
stack is a collection of AWS resource
and it can be managed as a single unit
and the cloud formations template
defines the stack in which the resource
can be created deleted or updated in a
very predictable way and a stack can
have all the resources like web server
database server we PC the network and
the security configurations in a V PC
all that is required to run a web or a
database application now stack could be
nested as well with cloud formation we
can actually nest a stack with another
stack and that's going to create an
hierarchy of the stacks for example and
there's a very good picture that
explains how the stacks are nested in an
hierarchical way let's say stack P is
the root stack and that could be a
parent stack for the stack call r and
the stack call q and the same way the
stack called
r is a parent stack for the stack s and
that these tag S is the valence tag for
D and Q you get that right so stacks can
always be nested it's possible cloud
formation allows us to create a
Microsoft Windows stack based on ma
on ec2 windows a.m. eyes and provide us
with the ability to install software and
use a remote desktop to access our stack
and update the configuration offer stack
and these tasks can be run on Windows
server instances there are a number of
pre-configured templates available and
it's directly available to use from the
AWS website itself to name a few we have
templates available for sharepoint
running on and Windows Server 2008 r2 we
also have templates that create a single
server installation of Active Directory
it's running on a Windows server and in
fact we have templates available for
elastic beanstalk and some sample
applications that runs from and Windows
Server 2008 r2 let's talk about stack
sets stack said actually has taken the
attack level implementation to the next
level using add AWS CloudFormation
template we can define a stack set that
lets us to create stack in AWS account
across the globe by using just a single
template and after we create the stack
or after the stack set is defined are
creating updating or deleting the stack
in the target account and the region's
can also be specified by us so the stack
said it really extends the functionality
of the stacks by allowing us to create
update and delete stack across multiple
accounts regions in just a single
operation and using an administrator
account so we can define and manage an
AWS CloudFormation template and use the
template as the basis for provisioning
stacks into you know some selected
target accounts across a specified
region let's talk about cloud formation
access control with I am I can specify
the list of users or list of privileged
users who would have access to the cloud
formation template who can create update
and delete stack so that's how I am
helps me with having or putting a layer
of control over the cloud formation
service and we can also use service
roles service roles are the one that
allows a Tablas cloud formation to make
a call to a resource in a stack on the
user's behalf and I can also have stack
policies
and these stacked policies are applied
to the users who already have access to
the cloud formation service and these
policies are the ones that help the
users who attempt to update the stack
all right let's do a quick lab on
creating and lamp stack on an ec2
instance with a local my sequel database
for storage now we can do the other way
as well
I can pick an ec2 instance and install a
tea service on top of the other and that
can be done as well but that's gonna
take a lot of time now we're talking
about automating it we're talking about
you know provisioning and infrastructure
using a code and platform machine helps
us to do that so this is what we're
gonna do we're gonna create or we have
an CloudFormation template already and
we're gonna use that template the
prohibition of web instance and that is
gonna have look at that that's gonna
have my sequel installed in it that's
gonna have PHP that's gonna have PC TPD
servers installed in it and running and
it's also gonna have an a PHP website
running from it so that's gonna receive
information from the website and that's
gonna store that information in the
database that's very local to it this is
the template that defines that
environment all right this is a very
simple provisioning so let's provision
this environment let's create a stack
you're going to give a stack name
and a database password
right and which region is that this is
in California is that all right
now let me do one thing let me switch to
the Mumbai region or let me switch to
not Virgina region
not Virginia and from here actually let
me switch the Mumbai region
I just to be sure it's the same template
that we're provisioning right that's the
same template that we're provisioning
well let's give this name so it's gonna
be great it's could be simply long
simple on lamp stack and what could be
the DB password
and DB root password and what could be
the DB user
I'm going to keep the rest as defaults
and I'm going to launch alright so
there's an issue with the password
[Music]
password should only have alpha numeric
characters get that so let's go back and
create a new password
but it also needs to have eight
characters so what can be a password
you
look at that the template is actually
creating little sources and here in the
screen we can see the template that we
used to apply the environment
if you remember we have we discussed
about instant types in parameters right
the default instance type is t2 small
but these are also allowed to run
all right parameter section is the one
that was used to receive information
from us like the DB name the DB password
the DB root password DB user instance
type key name and SSH locations
right now this research section is
showing us the resource that it actually
created but it looks like it's rolling
back why would that be
give me a moment
you
[Music]
alright this is one live example any
time it could not provision or any if
there is an interruption that it could
not proceed it would simply roll back
and delete all the resources that it had
provision and that's what it did
now let me fix this
all right as a fix I have switched the
region because I had some issue with the
BBC that's gonna take time for me to
analyze and fix it so here we're gonna
understand about clot formation so I
thought I will run the cloud formation
from another we PC that I know is
working fine that's in not Virginia
all right let's provision this lamp
server which is running out of Linux
which has Apache installed on it which
has PHP and my sequel already installed
in it so one server gonna act as web and
DB server
all right so I'm gonna create a stack
and from here I'm gonna pick a sample
stack if we look at if we look at it in
the designer it's gonna provision one
lamp server and a security at that
security group attached to it there you
go
right so let's go ahead and create a
stack
right parameters are used to receive
input from us what could be the DV
password
and the DB user and let's like the key
name right I'm going to keep the rest as
default and I'm gonna create a stack all
right so our stack that we ran from the
template at the moment it's getting
created it's in progress
from Eric and watch the events as to
what is getting created at the moment
like I said you know a lot of these
would have already started out there are
dependencies you know which one needs to
get created first which one needs to get
created second all that it started out
by cloud formation itself and that
emitters are the values that we have
inputted and a resource tab is section
where we can find what resources are
being provisioned at the moment so to
begin with it created a security group
at the moment it's creating an instance
and output it's empty as of now we're
gonna come back and see it now output is
where we can get outputs of a finished
job let's say here I wanted an URL of
the server that got created so instead
of me without going to a couple of other
places within the console and find the
output of the URL or the the output of
the resource that was created I can
simply get it from here well this needs
to be defined in the templates first
once we define it in the template it's
gonna be made available like here right
so I can open the top and there you go
so it has it already has a database
locally installed and it's connected to
what if I launch an application on top
of it that will get connected to the
database which is very local and my
single server with web and database in
it is ready for production now while
we're talking about a lamp server a
single lamp server let's talk about
creating an environment like this which
has elastic load balancer VPC server
running an auto scaling group and
putting some restrictions that nobody
will be able to access the ec2 instance
directly but they should be able to
access
the ec2 instance are the data only
through the elastic load balancer this
is a bit complicated than the
environment that we've already created
let's see how this is done all right
in this lab who are we gonna create
elastic load balance to auto scaling
group which is going to create a load
balancer and an auto scaling group and
that auto scaling group receives and
traffic only from the load balancer so
here's the template and here's the
architecture that are we going to
provision
let me call it right and the keeper is
going to use is simply lawn keeper now
this is where the problem was now we
were selecting few subnets
so now if I provision it
and this is gonna take it's short time
to provision the resources
so through parameters we can see the
values that we have inputted
and the events look good no roll back
no not deletes and the resource section
shows the resource that it is creating
so previously created a target group
now it's creating the application load
balancer itself
all right so it created an a load
balancer and that had create a security
group
it created a launch configuration it at
the moment it's creating an web server
group
and the events look good with all green
and yellow green ones are completed
yellow ones are in progress we don't
have any red delete or rollback errors
so it looks good alright it took a while
and the resources have been created some
of them show that they're in progress
but the status of the stack is complete
all resources have been created and we
do have an output to access the URL
there you go
and remember there was another feature
of the cloud formation that was it
should restrict access I'm a direct
access to ec2 instance let's see if that
has been done
if I tried ax is using the load balancer
it lets me access but if I try to access
it using the ec2 instance IP or the DNS
name my connection won't go through
because it's blocked through the
security group but direct access through
the load balancer is allowed and that's
what we wanted to achieve through that
template alright so what are the key
takeaways we discussed about what is
cloud formation the components of cloud
formation and then we discussed about
how cloud formation actually works the
procedures involved in using cloud
formation and deploying the environment
and we looked at the components or
concepts in cloud formation template is
different stack is different template is
actually the court and stack is actually
the resourced and then we discussed or
we did a demo lamp which provisioned and
a lamp stack environment on an Linux
instance and then we did a demo on
building a complicated environment which
included elastic load balancer auto
scaling and ec2 instance and that was
allowing access to the website only
through the load balancer and was
restricting access when we access it
directly from the instance so directly
from the instance was denied all right
so it was a lengthy one yes but we
covered a lot of things in cloud
formation and I believe you really
enjoyed their whole session just as I am
I'll meet you in another section soon
thank you hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here